[موسيقى]
الصين الان بلا ادنى شك قوه كبرى او كل
هذا يعود الى اواخر السبعينات القرن
الماضي عندما قام دان شوبينج بفتح
الاقتصاد الصيني مما قادر
الى هذا النمو الاقتصاديه الكبير جدا عبر
العقود الماضيه مما سمح لصيني يمارس سيتي
ثقلها عسكريا ودبلوماسيا ايضا
موقفه دونجا حينها وهو لنحافظ على الهدوء
ونعز قواتنا والان حصل وصلوا الى هذه
القوه الى الحد الذي تستطيع ان تقوم فيه
اسهامات ايجابيه مثل مجال تحدثنا عنه
وتخفيض التوترات في الخليج العربي من اجل
مصلحه الجميع هنالك مناطق اخرى خاصه في
شرق الهادئ حيث الولايات المتحده والصين
بالتحديد لديهما خلافات وهنالك احتمال
لخروج التوترات عن الطاقه السيطره وهذا
يقلقنا جميعا ولكن حقيقه وصول الصين على
انها من القوى الكبرى في العالم اصولها
لهذه المرحله اتمنى ان تساهم بايجابيه
اكثر من السلبيه
[موسيقى]
اعتقد بان ال الصينيين بكل حضاره سيختارون
الحالات او الاوضاع التي يدخلون فيها ولن
يبذلوا جهود الدبلوماسيه لا يرون فيها
املا كبيرا بالنجاح ولا اعتقد انهم يرون
املا كبيرا من النجاح اذا ما ارادوا
التدخل بشكل مباشر في النزاع الاسرائيلي
الفلسطيني فسوف يستنتجون كما استنتج
الكثيرون بين طرف الخارجي الاساسي ولا
الولايات المتحده نظرا للعلاقات القويه
جدا بين امريكا واسرائيل لذلك اشكوا بان
الصينيين سيحاولون التداخل في هذا النزاع
[موسيقى]